hey folks so building interactive
experiences on the web today usually
involves sending some JavaScript down to
your users often quite a lot of it today
we're going to talk about some
strategies you can use to deliver that
JavaScript efficiently while still
giving users a really great experience
so I work on a web browser called chrome
and when users access your site you're
probably sending down a lot of files
from web browsers perspective this looks
a little bit like this it gets even
worse with h2 multiplexing so my
perspective is that as much as I love
JavaScript it may be the most expensive
part of your site by 4-byte javascript
is probably the most expensive resource
or shipping down to your users today and
I'd like to explain why I feel like that
so the median webpage today is currently
shipping down about 350 kilobytes of
minified and compressed JavaScript
uncompressed that bloats up to about a
megabyte of script now the experiences
that are shipping down this much
JavaScript are taking anywhere between
15 to 36 seconds to get interactive on
mobile devices now although I've said
3358 kilobytes here the reality is that
if we take a look at popular sites
they're actually shipping down a lot
more script than this we're hitting this
ceiling across both desktop and mobile
web where sites are often shipping
multiple megabytes worth of code that a
browser then needs to process now the
impact that this can have on loading a
web page is some weird and wonderful
quirks so the way that we take a look at
loading a web page today is that it's a
little bit of a journey it's kind of
like a film strip that has three key
moments in it there's is it happening is
it useful and is it usable is it
happening is the moment where you were
able to deliver some painted content to
the screen so the user can actually tell
hey this webpage is loading up is it
useful is the point where you've painted
content full text or something that
allows the user to derive value from the
experience and then is it usable as the
moment when a user can actually start
tapping around the experience and having
something happening so I mentioned this
term interactive earlier but what does
that actually mean or for a page to be
interactive it has to be capable of
respond
quickly to user input whether users
clicking on a link or scrolling through
a page they need to be able to see that
something's actually happening in
response to those taps and those actions
that they're making an experience that
is enables deliver on this is going to
frustrate your users now one place where
this can commonly happen is when folks
are server-side rendering their
experiences and then shipping a whole
bundle of JavaScript down right after to
populate and hydrate that experience out
now when a browser needs to run many of
the events that you're probably going to
need it's probably gonna do it on the
same thread that handles user input now
that thread is called the main thread or
the UI thread if you happen to be
shipping down lots of expensive Java
Script that can end up blocking the main
thread so let's take a look at what you
expect will probably happen so here's an
example where you know maybe you're
gonna go and tap around the UI you might
check a check box or click a link and
everything's gonna work perfectly fine
but if we simulate blocking the main
thread nothing's able to happen at the
moment we're not able to check that
checkbox any links that we click are not
necessarily gonna do we expect because
we're blocking that thread so you want
to start moving away from doing those
types of things now this idea of
JavaScript impacting interactivity is
something we're seeing across lots of
different types of sites too much
JavaScript in general can actually delay
interactivity for visible elements and
this is a problem for many sites
including Google so we run into this in
sites like Google search so here are a
few examples where you know you could
start tapping around the UI but if we're
shipping too much JavaScript down there
could be some delay in there before
something actually happens and the user
may end up feeling a little bit
frustrated so that's an experience that
we want to move away from when it comes
to time to interact if we feel that you
should probably be getting interacted in
about under five seconds there's nothing
actually on this person's screen here so
they may be going through withdrawal
symptoms of some sort ideally we'd love
to shift the web to a position where
we're designing a little bit more for
resilience interactivity can heavily
impact a lot of things it can be
impacted by a person loading your web
site on a mobile data plan or coffee
shop Wi-Fi or just them being on the go
and not
necessarily having a consistent network
connection and when this happens and you
have a large payload of JavaScript that
needs to be processed they can end up
waiting for the site to actually render
anything or if something does render
they can be waiting a long time before
they can actually tap around and have
something happen
ideally shipping less JavaScript would
lead to a point where they're not
necessarily running into those cases now
to explain why javascript is such a big
deal and why it can have such a large
cost I'd like to walk you through what
happens when you send content down to a
browser so a user goes and they types in
an address bar in a type sent undressing
to their omnibox their address bar a
request is made out to a server which
will then have to return some markup the
browser needs to parse that markup and
get out the CSS the JavaScript the
images that are necessary and then the
browser actually has to process all of
those resources this is actually an
accurate depiction of what happens in
chrome when we're trying to process
everything that you send down now
although this looks great one of the
challenges here is that JavaScript can
actually end up being a bottleneck so
ideally we want to be able to paint
pixels quickly and then have the page
interactive but if javascript is a
bottleneck you can end up just looking
at something that you can't actually tap
around with an experience so we want to
move away from JavaScript itself being a
bottleneck to modern experiences one
thing to keep in mind as an industry is
that if we want to be fast at JavaScript
we actually have to be fast at
downloading that script parsing it and
compiling it that means that we have to
be fast at the network transmission side
of things but also the processing side
of things for our scripts because if
you're spending a long time parsing and
compiling script in a JavaScript engine
that can delay how soon a user can
interact with your experience now to
provide some data about this here is a
breakdown of where v8 the JavaScript
engine in chrome actually spends its
time while is trying to load up the page
containing script so in the orange we
have all the time being spent parsing
the JavaScript the popular sites are
sending down in yellow is the time we
spent compiling and together these take
up anywhere up to 30% of the time it
takes us to load up the JavaScript for
your page this is a real cost no another
thing to keep in
mine with JavaScript is that all bytes
are not equal when it comes to the web
200 kilobytes of scripts and 200
kilobytes worth of image have very
different weights they might take the
same amount of time to download but when
it comes to processing we're dealing
with very different amounts of costs a
JPEG image needs to be decoded
rasterized eventually get painted on the
screen a javascript bundle needs to be
downloaded and then parse compiled
executed there are a number of other
steps that an engine needs to complete
just be aware that these costs are not
quite equivalent and one of the reasons
why these cost start to add up and
matter is mobile so mobile itself is a
spectrum many of us here today probably
have a high-end or median end phone and
the realities that our users may not
necessarily have those device classes
they may be on a low-end phone they may
be on a median phone and the disparity
between these multiple classes of
devices can be quite stark due to
thermal throttling difference in cache
sizes CPU GPU you can end up
experiencing quite different processing
times for resources like JavaScript
depending on the device you're using so
here's a breakdown of how long it takes
to parse JavaScript from a range of
different types of devices at the very
top we have high end devices which
generally process it pretty quickly the
very bottom we've got our low end
devices and in the middle we've got our
average phones so things like the Moto G
4 or the Moto G 5 now take a look at how
much longer that script takes to process
we can we can actually try to look at a
more practical version of this so here
is the JavaScript startup time and
processing time for CNN comms JavaScript
on an iPhone 8 using the a 11 processing
chip that they have it takes nine
seconds less to process JavaScript then
it does an average phone nine seconds
that's nine seconds quicker that that
experience would be loading and
interactive on an iPhone than something
more average this hints that another
thing that maybe we need to stop
necessarily taking fast networks and CPU
and high RAM for granted fast devices
can actually sometimes be slow you can
be running multiple things on there fast
networks can be slow variability can
making absolutely everything slow you
may have users that you know are not
going to have the the latest and
greatest phone they might have something
more average and so it becomes really
important for us to start testing on
real phones and real networks so if your
team are able to take a look at their
annelids and understand exactly what
devices your users are actually
accessing your site with that I'll give
you a hint at what devices you should
probably have in the office to test out
your experience is using if you're not
able to afford those you just can't get
approval for it
check out webpagetest slash easy we have
a number of profiles set up there that
you can go and use today that already
have popular devices can pre-configured
we've got some median mobile devices
like the Moto G 4 already in there and
it's also really important to test on
representative networks now although
I've been talking about you know the
notion of low end and median phones
being important brian holt made this
really great point yesterday which is
it's really important to know your
audience not every single site it needs
to work great on 2g on a low-end phone
you may well have a wide range of users
on sort of the higher end of the
spectrum or in a different part of the
spectrum
just be aware of the data behind your
sites that you can make a reasonable
call on how much all of this matters so
if you want to be fast at javascript
download times are going to be pretty
critical for low end networks the things
you can do there are just ship less code
minify your source take advantage of
compression so gzip brought Leeza fly
take advantage of caching for repeat
visits parse times are pretty critical
for phones that have a slower CPU now on
the server if you're sort of a back-end
developer a full stack developer you
know that you kind of get what you pay
for with respect to CPU disk network as
we build sites that are increasingly
more reliant on JavaScript we sometimes
pay for what we send down in ways that
we don't always easily see so the shape
of success there is what can we do to
send the least amount of scripts through
our users while still giving them a
useful experience now one of the useful
things that you can do to accomplish
that today one of the greatest tools in
your tool belt
is code splitting so code splitting is
this idea that instead of stripping down
your users
massive JavaScript monolithic bundle
sort of like a massive full pizza what
if you were to just send them one slice
at a time so the smallest amount of
script that they need just to get the
current page useful enough for them to
use
now Co splitting can be done at a page
level at a route level at a component
level and this is something that's well
supported by many modern libraries and
frameworks it's well supported in web
pack so consider code splitting it's not
this sort of you know theoretical thing
either many large teams have been seeing
really great wins off the back of
investing in code splitting recently so
both Twitter and tinder as part of
rewriting their mobile web experiences
and trying to make sure that users are
able to interact with their sites as
soon as possible so anywhere up to a 50%
improvement in their time to interactive
just by adopting aggressive code
splitting inside their experiences
another thing that many of these sites
have done is adopted auditing as part of
their workflow thankfully the JavaScript
ecosystem has got a number of great
tools here so things like web pack
bundle analyzer which allows you to scan
using the source maps of your scripts
all of your dependencies that you're
including in your bundle and I help
strident af-- I sort of those places
where you have libraries that are
perhaps larger than you thought they
might be you might have NPM installed
yourself into some performance problems
just because you know you needed to ship
something and include a date library or
a UI library that was a little larger
than you thought it might be also great
for spotting places where you're
including duplicate code so just take
advantage of you know some of these
tools for auditing if you're really
unsure whether you have any issues with
JavaScript performance in general check
out lighthouse so lighthouse is one of
those tools by the chrome team that
we've baked into the chrome developer
tools it's also available as a Chrome
extension and the idea here is that it
gives you this really in-depth
performance analysis engine that will
highlight places where you can be doing
better one of the things we've recently
shipped in lighthouse is a feature
called JavaScript boot up time this
allows you to highlight places where
scripts might be spending quite a long
time in parsing and compiling and
executing so you can try to look at
opportunities to either you know split
up those scripts or just be doing a
little bit less work there another thing
you can do is try to make sure that
you're not shipping on
use code down to your users something
that's also baked into chrome developer
tools is code coverage code coverage is
really useful because it allows you to
just load up your site inside a chrome
and then you can start interacting with
your pages and it'll highlight all of
the code that's actually been used or
unused on a per script level and as you
start interacting it'll actually update
in real time those different bars to
show you know in red versus green how
much is unused versus used this can be
really great for identifying
opportunities to split up your scripts
or in some cases maybe no you know not
even load them up on initial load maybe
they could be deferred to the later
point in time so taking a look at
production examples where some of these
ideas have been useful I was talking to
the Netflix team last week and they
mentioned that there was this point
where when you land it on Netflix com
they had a non-member landing page flow
that they wanted to optimize they were
initially using react on both the server
side and the client side but they wanted
to make sure that their times
interactive was as good as possible and
so what they ended up doing was actually
dropping react just for the client-side
portion we're still using it on the
server side but they pre fetched it for
subsequent navigations deeper into the
user experience this improved their time
to interactive by 50% which is huge it
meant that users could sign up a little
bit quicker and it was worth the time
investment here another thing that
Netflix mentioned was that there was a
point where they were trying to move
their video playback component so the
component that you see whenever you're
trying to play anything on Netflix from
vanilla JavaScript over to react so this
was the identical UI you know for both
versions of this thing and they
experienced some negative results
initially they found that the extra
JavaScript costs for downloading parsing
evaluating and the runtime costs for
using virtual Dom diffing we're quite
high and they ended up causing a few
negative results so reductions in Play
hours reductions in usage and so they
ended up needing to spend a little while
actually reducing these costs to enable
them to finally roll out react for the
video player to I want it to highlight
what this actually looked like so here
we have an example using phrenology
there was no interference on the main
thread so your interactive pretty
quickly and then we have a busy main
thread example where all of that
JavaScript processing meant that it took
a few seconds before the user could
actually start interacting with the
video player as I mentioned there
thankfully in a much better place now
and they've been able to ship out this
experience to users but keeping an eye
on their time to interactive and their
JavaScript costs was critical to them
enabling future experimentation that
used react now if you're looking for a
pattern for serving JavaScript
efficiently to your users i heavily
recommend checking out purple or PR PL
so purple is a pattern that stands for
push render pre cache and lazy load and
it's a pattern for aggressively Co
splitting where you just ship down the
kodi user needs for every single route
and then you take advantage of service
worker for pre caching the JavaScript
and logic needed for future routes and
lazy load it as needed what this means
is that when a user ends up navigating
to other views and the experience
there's a good chance it's already in
the cache and so they experience much
much reduced costs in terms of booting
this up and getting interactive so we've
talked about a few ideas you know if you
care about performance if you've ever
you know worked on our web / for your
site you know that sometimes you could
end up working on a fix coming back a
few weeks later and someone on your team
may have been working out a feature or
unintentionally you know broken the
experience you know you could be in a
position where you just fixed the site
and someone comes along you're like why
why did you ruin it why thankfully there
are ways that we can we can try to work
around this and one way is having a
performance budget in place so
performance budgets are great because
they keep everybody on the same page it
creates a culture or shared enthusiasm
for constantly improving the user
experience and it holds the team
accountable performance budgets can be
employed it's sort of a file size level
so you could have you know budgets based
on JavaScript chunks you could have
budgets around speed metrics so time to
interactive or other metrics like first
content feel pain this is a feature this
is an idea that is well supported and
tools like speed curve or calibre and so
if you're interested in trying to get
performance budget
setup there are number tools you can try
out just to roll this out for your team
heavily recommend it if you're
interested in trying to track the cost
of JavaScript in production for your
real users there are two things I'd
recommend checking out the first is the
long tasks API so this is an API that we
recently shipped in chrome allows you to
gather real-world telemetry on parsing
compile as well as culprits basically
long tasks are any task that lasts
longer than 50 milliseconds that could
be problematic on the main thread and
you can record that and log it back to
your Google Analytics another thing to
check out is first input delay now this
is a metric that measures the time from
a user first trying to interact with the
experience and the brows are actually
responding with something so this is
still an early metric we actually have a
polyfill available for it today that you
can go and check out between these two
you should hopefully be able to get
enough to lemma tree from real users to
understand what JavaScript performance
problems they're running into so
improving performance is a journey it's
generally not something you're just
gonna do you know all in one go and be
done with it's usually a journey where a
lot of small changes can actually lead
to pretty big gains I don't you know i
don't expect most people especially if
they have javascript performance
problems to go out and fix everything
tonight you know the ìiî try to compare
this to the experience that you might
have if someone asked you to learn how
to sketch out something like a baby for
example if someone told you to go and
learn how to draw a baby you probably
look up tutorial and maybe the first
step would be drawing you know the
outline the second step is probably
drawing the rest of the baby but that's
not the expectation I have of everybody
here which you probably will do is you
know make a few incremental improvements
to your experience maybe you'll chip
away a little bit at the JavaScript and
you may end up here which is actually
you know not a bad place to be it's a
little bit better than the first one but
over time if you were able to continue
investing in improving the JavaScript
performance of your site's making sure
that you're able to get interactive
really quickly your users will thank you
because they're actually going to be
able to do things much much more quickly
so I hope some of that was useful that's
it for me thank you
you